just to bring you a bit more details
from the full letter that we have now
got this letter from the prime minister
to Nadeem zahari dated today he says
when I became prime minister last year I
pledged that the government I lead would
have integrity professionalism and
accountability at every level that is
why following new information which came
to light in recent days regarding your
personal financial arrangements and
decorations I asked the Laurie Magnus
the independent advisor on Minister's
interests to fully investigate this
matter you agreed and undertook to
cooperate fully with the inquiry
following the completion of the
independent advisors investigation the
findings of which he has shared with us
both it is clear that there has been a
serious breach of the ministerial codes
as a result I've informed you of my
decision to remove you from your
position in his Majesty's government he
goes on to say that Nadeem zahari should
be extremely proud of his achievements
over the five years referencing the
vaccine procurement program
in particular and the fact that he's a
kurdish-born Iraqi Refugee that's
something which people up and down this
country have rightly valued uh Rishi
Cena says in this letter but just to sum
summarize it is clear this morning that
the investigation has completed uh into
Nadim zahawi the findings have been
shared with both the Prime Minister and
Nadeem zahawi himself and as a result
the uh Rishi soon at the Prime Minister
says it's clear there has been a serious
breach of the ministerial code and as a
result he has been sacked from the
government
let's go